There's this one
map you have to see to understand
the full effects of war.
Right now,
there's a civil war happening in Sudan.
And like most conflicts,
it comes down to two guys who want power.
And in the process,
they're willing to disrupt
the lives of millions of people.
This map shows us
how many people have
had to flee their country
because of this war.
These people are leaving their homes
and fleeing to Sudan's
neighbors like Chad and Egypt.
The reports say that over
5 million people have been displaced
because of this conflict.
If you want to understand
the roots of this conflict,
go check out the whole video
we made on the channel.
And if you want to better understand
global politics, follow along for more.